this morning we're hearing from a
survivor in the massive sex abuse
scandal that's rocking the southern
baptist convention the sbc just held its
first annual meeting since a bombshell
report came out it claims executives
hushed up hundreds of allegations of
abuse delegates at the meeting including
alleged survivors voted for a new
president and other reforms nikki betty
spoke to a survivor pressing for change
at that meeting we warn you some of the
some of these details are disturbing
he
made sure he picked me up first and
dropped me off last man this is the the
youth minister at a
monster church that's given me all this
time it was that level of attention from
frankie wiley the youth minister at a
southern baptist mega church in georgia
in the 1980s that a young david pittman
says he craved i'm thinking i'm special
looking back now was frankie wiley
grooming you then absolutely not just me
he groomed the family he groomed the
church and as it turns out he was
grooming the entire state he has victims
all over the state of georgia you were
12 years old when frankie wiley began
sexually abusing him right so it started
with sleepover and it would be
you know oral
he
digital insertion you know you you name
it it occurred in the bed
and for me it was i froze pittman now 54
says wiley raped him repeatedly until he
was 15. in the southern baptist church
we don't even talk about sex much less
sexual abuse pittman says he finally
found the courage to report his sexual
abuse to the police in 2005 but legal
action was impossible because the
criminal statute of limitations had
passed so he says he then told numerous
church leaders they said there's nothing
we can do nearly 40 years later this
explosive 288-page investigative report
by independent firm guidepost solutions
alleges how the southern baptist
convention's executive committee
stonewalled survivors including pittman
it details how the church ignored
pittman's and other victims sexual abuse
allegations against frankie wiley
telling pittman there was nothing he
could do but pray what was your reaction
to the report
i was nauseated
pastor roland slade a member of the sbc
executive committee was among hundreds
of church leaders at its annual meeting
in anaheim california this week where
the sbc vowed to change the affirmative
has it
the recommendations passed
two recommendations an updated abuse
task force and a database to track
credibly accused ministers and pastors
the task force said the system would
also be retroactive and would attempt to
identify abusers and remove them from
the church even if the statute of
limitations passed on the accusations
i've spoken with survivors who just
simply do not believe there will be
institutional change
and nikki i'm sad
for that and but i understand that
and i understand that we've we've talked
a lot and we're really trying to make a
a really
a monumental shift in how we handle
sexual abuse as a convention of churches
david pittman traveled 2500 miles to
attend the sbc meeting it's where we sat
down he gave me this 2019 email in which
frankie wiley confesses to sexually
abusing five boys it's a relief that
it's on paper
finally you're being believed
right
the the person that committed these
crimes has acknowledged them and said
yes he just felt sick that
i was just a gratification and an evil
person as we sit here frankie wiley is a
music minister in a church in georgia
yes ma'am
you can see wiley playing the piano at
trinity community church in georgia this
past sunday it's a church that recently
cut ties with the sbc did he ever
apologize to you
he tried if he's locked up one day
that'll be apology that'll that's the
apology i would like to see
i spoke with two other men who share
similar stories of sexual abuse by
frankie wiley as young boys i reached
out to wiley and trinity community
church in georgia where he works but
have not heard back wiley has never been
charged with a crime and that's a really
important point so many survivors and
victims not just of the southern baptist
church but the catholic church
say they feel that criminal statute of
limitations really protect these
predators david wiley as a 15 year old
says he only had five years to go to
police wow wow it's that much time yeah
you're processing that information it's
absolutely absolutely yeah in a time
when we weren't talking about sexual
assault and the church in the community
where as he pointed out this was not
discussed right and the why the why they
didn't believe him wow all those other
kids
all right thank you nicky